nick can you pull up a geoduck and show
them what it looks like a geoduck
yes duck yeah
gooey duck gooey duck it's like a c
yeah there you go another version of
like a clam
oh and don't you don't you stroke them
and then they spit
so they're what you're disgusting so
what you're supposed to do is
like slice it kind of like what you do
with the uh tongue
but there are videos of asian women
eating this and they'll just take a bite
out of it
and after you cook it for some reason
like water squirts out of them it looks
like a dick
is it some kind of weiner no that's yeah
that's a clamp it's a it's like a clamp
oh
[Music]
look at this girl
she's not feeling it
that thing bid back on all right
i'll tell you what she's taking that
thing down though like a chair all right
chef you might have found a secret
ingredient
fry some of these up chef oh original
recipe right here
let me see another one oh my gosh
who is this girl she's creeping me out
oh wow giant
oh no damn girl
[Music]
oh girl get it oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
bad guy
bad guy papa like girl
you gotta drain that thing yeah oh
man this is sexual as [ __ ] oh man
damn girl bad guy bad guy
the way she just
that one's still looking good
that one's still flirting dude damn boy
we back at brother's bar
and this girl is about to get knocked
out right here
oh is that pepper she's rubbing that in
oh
oh that's a kneecap dude that's a
grandparent's leg right there
uh-oh there she goes with that sami sosa
sauce right there boy it looks like
chili oil
and chin do you know what she's saying i
don't know it's chinese this is chinese
okay
thank you oh she put some tempura crunch
roll on that [ __ ] all right
that's like crunchy that lime seasoning
is getting crunchy girl
hmm
that's what that is yeah dude we should
get one and try it
we can't do this yeah i bet you can play
boy
oh
gosh damn is that thing aftermarket
it's just are we watching the dark web
is this the dark web how many are there
now
oh good oh it's a four minute video of
her just doing this over and over
probably a million views and are these
good if has anybody had one of these
i've actually had it before the way
you're supposed to eat it which is
sliced
so you're not supposed to just kind of
take a bite out of it like that and
i want to take the fun out of it yeah
what they do i want to slap it around
and bite that thing
why why are they i just don't uh
oh it says the go duck is still alive i
feel like this is
some way inhumane it's actually pretty
sad watching her smack it knowing that
it's still alive
she didn't prepare it right what did it
do that was so bad is what i wanted
and please be gentle
and it's scary bro someone needs to stop
this woman i agree with that
someone said
[Laughter]
so i'm gonna delete my search history
just in case
oh she said when she started slapping
you know a man wronged her once or twice
oh man oh that's too much man oh
someone netflix are you still watching
someone's daughter
this is disgusting is she draining them
this thing that's mother nature man
that's yeah damn mother nature's a
sexual clam brown